come out i want all demons out of our
spine get out have you ever watched
something online or on tv
and wondered was that real get out in
the name of jesus christ get out
there's probably no show that makes
people ask that question more than
nathan fielders nathan for you
nathan for you is a parody reality
television show where fielder gives
ridiculous advice to small business
owners the show's humor comes from his
guests reacting to the bizarre and
uncomfortable circumstances he creates
the plan ship smoke detectors tax-free
by re-branding them
as musical instruments
you know some degree of the show has to
be set up nathan's ideas are
intentionally ridiculous and the guests
know they're on a show yet their
reactions feel so authentic
that you can't help but wonder could
that have really happened i don't know
if you're really trying to do this just
for the show but
i'd like to get off my desk and i'm
going to ask you to leave the office if
you search for nathan fielder online the
question of whether he's acting or not
is one of the top results and the
mystery of how
real the show is is debated relentlessly
online even in the show's finale fielder
notes the blurred line between reality
and fiction
and the more we kept shooting things the
harder it was to tell where the show
ended and life began and nathan for you
isn't the only show that has this effect
people wonder the same thing about
reality stars internet celebrities and
even pro wrestlers it's actually a
pretty common question
especially in a social media influenced
world where people's daily lives are put
on display and
monetized so it's no surprise that
people are fascinated with characters
like nathan with that in mind let's take
a look at nathan for you
and other reality blurring entertainment
to really understand the question
is nathan fielder acting this
is nathan for you from the very start of
the show we get a sense of who nathan
is he's overly confident combative and
socially awkward if you want to
hang out sometime outside i don't know
it's fine this scene with the yogurt
shop manager introduces us to the show's
central theme
nathan's inability to connect with
others it's something that comes up
again and again throughout the show you
know what you are
you remind me of the wizard of
loneliness from the beginning his
extreme social awkwardness seems too
intense to be real
in an interview with the av club nathan
admitted to exaggerating his character
on the show for the sake of humor
he says that quote there's some of me in
there but he's also quote taking a lot
of vulnerabilities and insecurities that
i had when i was younger and i'm
exaggerating them for the sake of comedy
what we don't know is how much of that
social awkwardness is genuine nathan and
how much of it comes from his on-screen
persona
in a sense he's no different from other
reality television hosts like gordon
ramsay who have created character
versions of themselves that they play on
tv
in ramsey's case you can really see how
much the character changes depending on
the circumstance in the american version
of kitchen nightmares he's completely
over the top
look at the nest of this place it's
[ __ ] ridiculous
whereas in the british version he's
still his bombastic self but much more
subdued
that was upsetting because that was
[ __ ] dire
like ramsay you get a range of nathan's
persona throughout the show
in some moments of nathan for you you
can see he's playing it up for the sake
of humor they did all the hard work they
did reserve the plus
they really did a good job if you're
lucky he could do some hard work
on him but in others like the ghost
realtor exorcism
he seems genuinely shocked and concerned
for her safety are you okay
the obvious reason for comparing nathan
for you with reality television is that
the show itself is a direct parody of
business improvement reality shows like
kitchen nightmares and undercover boss
and if it wasn't for the dominance of
reality television in today's
entertainment neither nathan for you nor
nathan's character would exist
it's easy to overlook just how
influential reality television has been
on the entertainment industry from the
way people perceive celebrities to its
impact on characters in scripted media
but perhaps the most obvious change was
the complete transformation of channels
like mtv and the history channel both
were once known for thoughtful and
original programming but now almost
exclusively show reality television this
dramatic change can be traced back to
one mtv show from the early 90s the real
world
ironically the creators of the real
world originally set out to write a
scripted drama in the style of beverly
hills 90210 and melrose place to
capitalize on the allure of the
glamorous hollywood lifestyle they
ultimately scrapped the idea after
realizing that writing a script and
casting real actors would be too
expensive
instead they devised a way to capture
that same glamorized lifestyle but on a
much lower budget
inspired by the 1973 pbs drama and
american family they cast
seven real 20-somethings put them in a
duplex in soho and filmed them 24 7.
the producers told the cast to act as
naturally as possible with the goal of
editing all that footage down into a
coherent story
of their everyday lives find out what
happens what when people stop being
polite could you get the phone
and start getting real the real world
the show worked it was a cheap way to
give people the same kick they would
have gotten from a scripted drama it
spawned countless other shows looking to
generate entertainment while keeping
costs low
like big brother and survivor and led to
mtv cutting their music videos and the
history channel ending its big budget
documentaries the reality television
genre continues to expand today
adding countless sub-genres from dating
shows to court shows to business
improvement
these shows all work the same way film
lots of unscripted footage and use
fast-paced editing to construct a story
in post-production
nathan for you parodies these shows by
subverting many of their common tropes
reality television shows a stylized
portrayal of real events
shows like the bachelor use rapid
editing voice over and intense music
cues to steer the narrative of the show
i'm gonna give you these to hold on to
that's kind of dominatrix but nathan for
you clues you into the facade if you
compare nathan for you to conventional
reality television shows you'll notice
that nathan for you has much fewer cuts
because it keeps in the imperfections
so exciting yeah it is huh yeah
[Music]
by getting rid of the editing techniques
that hide the messier truth nathan4u not
only satirizes the over-dramatized
editing style of reality tv
but it exposes the constant performance
of the on-screen characters
because nathan is so awkward we know the
only reason that the contestant tries to
kiss him is to perform for the cameras
but while nathan for you uses editing to
expose the performances by people on the
show you never see nathan himself
completely
break character in fact by stripping
down the artificial editing and showing
him
interacting in real time with people
confused by his behavior his on-screen
performance seems that much more real
the question of the extent of nathan's
performativity remains a mystery
reality television made the concept of
performing for the camera so ubiquitous
that it worked its way into scripted
media too
compare how similar kinds of characters
treat the camera before
and after the start of reality
television the mockumentary this is
spinal tap is a scripted comedy that
follows a fictional rock band and it
came out before reality television
you'll notice that the characters have
the same personality on and off stage
and it feels like we're seeing their
authentic selves not some fake
performance for the camera
the office on the other hand does the
exact opposite david brent clearly
notices the camera and performs
differently because the camera is there
that kind of character only resonates in
a modern post-reality television world
where the audience understands how the
presence of a camera
influences a person's behavior brent's
obsession with performing for an
audience gives us insight into his
character and shows his desperate need
to be liked he wants to make himself
appear more interesting than he really
is
i mean just be yourself yeah get a bit
more relaxed
something like that so even before
nathan for you clued in on the
artificiality of reality television
shows like the office showed characters
performing only because the camera is
there
and it's not just mockumentaries the
show fleabag also centers on a character
who like david brent
is trapped in a performance for the
camera she uses the audience to tell
jokes and lighten the mood and we become
her sort of confidant but when we see
her at her most vulnerable she's
uncomfortable with our presence and the
camera backs off i'm just trying to get
to know you i don't want that
the audience is both a refuge and a
crutch a way to distract herself from
her misery and avoid confronting her
trauma both shows were influenced by
reality television because they show
characters presenting the audience with
an idealized version of themselves
instead of showing their true identities
but it's not just people on television
that have to perform all the time
you do too so
that's right in 1956
irving goffman wrote a book called
presentation of the self that gives
insight into why reality television
became so popular
he claims that all interactions are
essentially tiny theatrical performances
where we try to shape the impressions
others have of us through our appearance
speech and manner
essentially in our public lives we play
the character we hope others see
us as but to goffman we don't always get
to pick which role we play
sometimes social norms require us to
play particular roles even though we
might not do so naturally like a
waitress who must remain calm and
courteous to a rude patron the last four
times we've come here
the food was awful well uh
i apologize for the food the last few
times
our true selves only emerge backstage
when we are alone or with people we
trust
there we drop all performance and become
our authentic self
i just don't understand what would
compel a person to be
such a [ __ ] to a total stranger
countless character driven stories show
the conflict between the onstage self
and the backstage self
a character like shyron in moonlight
acts tough when playing the role of the
drug dealer but reveals his vulnerable
side when in private with kevin
goffman's theory explains why we enjoy
this kind of narrative storytelling
these stories let us see a person's
backstage in a way we never would have
otherwise the appeal of reality
television then is that we not only get
to see a person's backstage but it's the
backstage of an actual real person
not a character in a fictional story the
theory also explains why the contestants
in the hunk acted the way they did the
women weren't showing their backstage
selves but rather they were playing a
particular role that they had seen in
other reality television shows they knew
they had to act flirty and over the top
to make it into the cut
like a waitress playing out her social
role so too do reality television stars
and online influencers play the role of
the friend or the romantic
interest or the social outcast because
those are the social norms they
implicitly agreed to perform but for the
reality television shows that nathan for
you parodies this performance is hidden
from view the shows instead present
themselves as a glimpse into the
backstage life of the people on it many
of their titles imply that we're getting
the real
personal experience of glitzy socialites
like with the real world
the real housewives and keeping up with
the kardashians by surveilling the cast
of the real world 24
7 the show appears to break through
people's onstage performances and expose
their authentic selves
of course it turns out reality tv isn't
so authentic after all the real world
chicago was shot in 2001
and happened to be filming during 9 11.
the show dealt with the events head on
showing reactions from the cast watching
the event unfold on live tv
it's a compelling scene that still
circulates on the internet to this day
because it captures the shock people
felt watching 911 unfold in an authentic
manner but in reality the scene was
staged the cast later admitted they were
at wrigley field for a photo shoot when
they learned of the attacks
only afterwards did they shoot a scene
of their supposed initial reaction there
are numerous examples of the fabrication
behind reality television the extreme
makeover home edition renovations are
apparently not really built to last
bachelor relationships often break down
off-camera and the kardashians tend to
keep their family drama like
kim and kanye's divorce private until it
airs on their show and it turns out that
nathan for you similarly stages events
on the show
the actress from the hero episode said
producers told her she was on an mtv
dating show and she knew that the person
she was on a date with was in disguise
and in an ama on reddit nathan said he
made sure he could get out of the
handcuffs in the claw of shame episode
but despite some deception on the show
some events are not only completely real
but they actually go on to have a real
world impact fielder's clothing line
summit ice became a real successful
brand and some of his guests ended up
embracing his
silly ideas and using them on their own
like the ghost realtor
similarly nathan's personality extends
beyond the show itself he keeps up his
deadpan awkward persona in moments where
celebrities normally seem more genuine
um
we lose every year to saturday night
live so i didn't
um prepare anything he even did an
entire episode about faking a story for
a talk show
a type of show that presents itself as
authentic but like many things on
tv is just a performance but what you
could never guess
is that this seemingly effortless
appearance was one of the most
calculated events in human history
[Music]
nathan is far from the only actor
staying in a character all the time
in professional wrestling this behavior
is encoded in a law that governs the
entire industry
kayfabe kfame is the act of staying in
character and maintaining a suspension
of disbelief pretending that all the
fights
feuds and other narrative plot lines are
real it's an open secret that pro
wrestling is staged and match outcomes
are pre-written
but everyone from the wrestlers to the
industry professionals must maintain the
ruse
like the reality star pro wrestlers
don't get to have a backstage
they perform all the time nowadays kfame
is more of a wink and a nod rather than
a governing rule
most fans understand that vince mcmahon
didn't actually father an illegitimate
son who just so happens to be the
leprechaun wrestler hornswoggle
but back in the day people did debate
about how real pro wrestling was
it's still real to me damn it just like
how the internet now debates whether or
not nathan fielder is axing
nathan is in a version of kfabe as well
his awkward persona from nathan for you
shows up everywhere
even on his personal youtube channel his
videos basically resemble something a
socially unaware person would post
unironically down to the low quality
webcam
if it's all a bit it's something he's
maintained constantly just like the
kayfabe maintained by pro wrestlers it
even extends to his instagram posts like
this one where he's supposedly out on
the town with friends but they're all
just out of frame laughing too
the fact that nathan's instagram posts
are in character really adds to the
mystery of whether or not he's
acting social media just like reality tv
is supposed to be a window into
someone's backstage persona so even
though this instagram post seems like a
continuation of his ongoing joke on
nathan for you that he has no friends it
still feels plausible that the person is
real
his behavior online feels a lot like
other social media influencers who also
have dramatic
over-the-top personas for the camera and
market their posts as a peek into their
backstage
really every youtuber who actually shows
their face offers the same thing the
real world did
authenticity except this time the
production costs are even cheaper and
the actors don't go home when the season
ends they sometimes vlog
every day and document their entire
lives for them the performance extends
even further into the backstage
their life is content and the line
between backstage and onstage becomes
even more blurred
but this behavior isn't just reserved
for actors wrestlers or influencers
now with the mass availability of social
media everyone has the ability to star
in their own little reality show just
like the cast of the real world people
on social media present themselves to an
audience on a daily basis
they keep up the k-fave by performing
idealized versions of themselves and it
gets harder and harder to tell what's
authentic
and what's not the film 8th grade
explores this phenomenon and how social
media has impacted teenagers
pressures i had as a d-list celebrity
had been
democratized to an entire generation now
everyone feels like they can have their
own brand and everyone feels like they
have to present themselves
like a reality television character or
someone in kfabe
kayla puts on an appearance and the film
captures the flaws in that constructed
persona
similar to nathan for you's editing 8th
grade avoids cutting to keep in the most
authentic moments
unlike most online vlogs if you see a
lot of vlogs the uploaded video will be
jump cuts
and they'll cut out all the sort of
white noise that is the most interesting
thing
which does actually give you insight
into what they're actually doing
i like him he's a he's a really nice
person but
yeah i love him so while 8th grade
confronts the challenge of living in a
constant social media performance head
on
plenty of other stories deal with that
same anxiety the character fleeback
reflects the anxiety that comes with
constantly performing and not having a
distinction between the onstage self and
the backstage self
the show regularly shows her inability
to know what is just a performance
and what is her true self it's not a
change
i don't know maybe part of fleabag's
massive success is its ability to touch
on this uniquely modern social media
influenced post-reality television
anxiety
that very same anxiety is at the center
of nathan for you's
series finale in a surprising turn the
finale departs from the show's usual
format and instead follows bill heath
an actor who appeared on the show and
his quest to find a long lost
love is that a regret of yours i should
have murdered but as the episode
progresses it becomes unclear how much
of the relationship is real
and how much is an exaggeration made up
by bill for the sake of the cameras well
it seems like a personal moment for you
no bring the cameras i like all the pr
and nathan himself has his own identity
crisis after hiring an escort to help
bill work on his interpersonal skills
nathan finds that he enjoys her company
and continues to hire her throughout his
stay in little rock it's the culmination
of a series-long character arc the
wizard of loneliness finds someone to
connect with but the catch is that it's
only for the show
just like fleabag the show is a crutch
for nathan in it he can create a fantasy
world where he's a confident host
and can hire people to interact with him
because he has a television show macy is
just another character in that
performance
playing the role of an interested and
caring companion in the end both bill
and nathan live in a fantasy world where
the characters they try to play don't
reflect who they truly
are and because of that crisis neither
can truly connect with others that's
what makes it a perfect story for the
modern era what nathan
fleabag kim kardashian you and i all
have in common
is that we can get stuck in a constant
performance unable to discern what is
our authentic self and what is a
character
which brings us back to the original
question is nathan fielder acting
in a direct sense yes he is playing a
character who happens to be an
exaggerated version of his younger self
but when placed within the context of a
performative world where reality tv and
social media influencers dominate our
concept of authenticity
it's clear that nathan's character is no
less real than other supposedly real
people
on tv and that still doesn't tell the
entire story
because sometimes a performative
exaggerated version of yourself can be
more true to who you really
are i would say larry david is the guy
you see on curb your enthusiasm no
yes no yes because that's that's who i
aspire to aspire to be yes so everything
else is an act
and i do think the performed version of
yourself is not
necessarily false who you hope to be
can be a more vulnerable truth than who
you are afraid you may be
by acknowledging that everyone is
performing from bill heath to the
contestants on the hunk to nathan
himself
nathan for you ironically gives us
something more authentic than the
reality television shows that claim to
sell
authenticity on the show we watch people
make conscious choices about how they
want to present themselves on television
and what character they want to play
in watching people make those choices we
get more insight into who that person is
than we would ever get from 24 hours of
camera surveillance
nathan for you is so special because it
exposes humanity's inherent desire to
perform to present a certain version of
the self
scripted media like fleabag and 8th
grade follow characters who have to deal
with that dilemma but nathan for you
shows it in real life
the blurring of the line between acting
and sincerity is exactly the point of
the show
it's in the not knowing that we get the
most authentic reactions and it's in the
not knowing that we catch a glimpse of
ourselves
so is nathan fielder acting i think a
much more interesting question is when
you're on a group call or posting on
social media or even commenting on this
video
are you this
is nathan for you
i do have some extra thoughts about
nathan fielder's performance that didn't
make it onto youtube and i included
those thoughts in an extended version of
this video on nebula
nebula is a streaming service that
supports exclusive ad-free videos from
youtube's top
education creators including some of my
favorite film youtubers like patrick
willems michael tucker and lindsay ellis
if you liked this episode the version of
nebula removes this ad entirely and
replaces it with a discussion of one
downside of nathan's reality bending
acting
you can watch the extended video on
nebula thanks to a partnership with
curiositystream a subscription streaming
service with thousands of documentaries
and non-fiction titles much like the
history channel and the discovery
channel before reality television took
over
in fact the founder of curiositystream
is also the founder of the discovery
channel so you get those same high
quality documentaries like david
attenborough's light on earth
a fascinating exploration of how animals
can produce light on their own
because curiosity stream wants to
support educational content and
educational creators if you sign up for
curiosity stream with the link in the
description you get access to curiosity
stream and
nebula for a limited time curiosity
stream is offering 26
off their annual plan that's less than
15 a year for both curiosity stream and
nebula which really is one of the best
deals in online streaming
clicking on that link in the description
is a great way to support me and this
channel as well as educational content
as a whole
along with nebula my patreon supporters
also got the extended edition
a big thanks to them for helping out the
channel thanks for watching